monitoring equip making sure you're okay
at just 18 alistair is prepared to put
his health at risk for the greater good
he wants doctors to deliberately infect
him with covid19
and then test a vaccine to see if it
protects him so you get a bed
you get a tv yeah you get a tv up there
yes it would mean spending weeks in
isolation so he didn't spread the virus
to anyone else
but he says it's worthwhile a trial
where i'm being deliberately infected
with coronavirus is not it's not a nice
thing to think about
for anyone and it's the same for me as i
would much prefer for there to be no
challenge trials and no pandemic but we
are in a pandemic
for me and for my family it's kind of
it's
they know why i'm doing what i'm doing
um and although they're worried that
obviously
they're like me they're cautiously
optimistic as to the benefits that
challenge child could bring
you know and they're hugely supportive
covid19 vaccines are currently tested in
clinical trials of thousands of people
to see whether they protect against the
disease as they go about their everyday
lives
but it takes months to get a result by
infecting a hundred or so young and
healthy volunteers
then giving them the vaccine in a
so-called challenge trial
scientists should know whether it works
within weeks in a time
when the pandemic is waxing and waning
because of
public health measures and so on um when
we can't
rely on the fact that there is
transmission in in the community to
to test the efficacy of vaccines um
challenge
trials can can really give you that
guarantee and let you progress with
vaccine development
um in a really sustained sort of way
young people are unlikely to get
seriously ill but there is the chance
they could develop
long covered the debilitating after
effects of infection
ethics experts say volunteers need to
understand the risks however small
particularly when there is no cure
because there's that altruism
that positivity um that really puts
extra focus on the importance of the
consent process
both in terms of understanding what
those risks are to the extent that
they're known because they're always the
uncertainties
but also i think understanding how
uncertain research is
scientists from the royal free hospital
and imperial college along with the
clinical trials company h vivo
hope to get ethical approval to start
the first trial in january
more than two and a half thousand young
volunteers have so far
come forward the government which is
putting up the money hopes the studies
will fast track
effective vaccines thomas more sky news